hey everybody it's Mike from motorflows
and welcome to today's video it's
Tuesday October 11 2022 and you know
it's been uh it's been over a week since
I released a video I I've been really
busy we've just released our new order
flows Trader 6 uh software upgrade and
you know it's a big uh difference in the
order flow you know we got 19 uh
indicators order flow based indicators
inside there as well as
um you know some improvements on ways to
analyze the Delta and basically
understand what's happening in the
market right because you know software
is
there to help you do your analysis now
what I'm going to talk about today is
imbalances now
I have a very paired down version here
of the footprint which is just basically
the your normal
bid ask footprint chart that you know
most people
um that you know are new to order flow
right they get a free version of a
footprint chart you know ninjatrader has
their volumetric
um you know and and there's there's
versions out there that are relatively
inexpensive and I'm showing you this tip
on using order flow imbalances because
you know if you're new to order flow you
know you want to know what to look for
and that's why I do these videos now you
know today we had you know pretty much
every Futures Market sold off about 145
in the afternoon this is uh the 10-year
notes but you know for example like gold
right 145 is when the big drop happened
you know crude oil a similar thing
obviously equities had that big drop at
roughly around the same time and you
know the thing with imbalances is
an imbalances is okay first let's define
it right what is an imbalance well you
know Market trade in a two-way auction
there's a bid and there's an offer so
when you have more volume traded on
either the bid or the offer you know the
bid versus the offer not horizontally
but in a two-way auction you know say
it's five bit at six if you have
um you know the sort of the industry
standard if you will is uh four to one
but again you don't have to use four to
one you could use three to one you could
use five to one you could do six to one
um you know it's really up to you but on
this chart I'm using you know four to
one which is you know fine for for most
most people yeah I think you'd probably
want to change it
um you know if you're really digging
deeper into order flow and you know
developing a trading plan around
imbalances maybe you want to refine it
uh based on the market that you're
looking at but again you know for most
Traders four to one is enough to
determine that there's an imbalance in
the market and
all right so where are we this is gold
here so it's a one minute chart okay so
the market started selling off right and
you see red bar Red Bar Red Bar Red Bar
um red bar but what are you seeing right
selling and balances right that's what
you expect to see on a market selling
off right that's normal right because
you have aggressive sellers in the
market right people hitting the bid more
than lifting the offer uh by you know a
percentage of four to one more hitting
the bid than lifting the offer that is a
selling and balance
now all of a sudden Market's still going
down but you're seeing buying imbalances
right right in here 15 you know 23 20 41
24 16. these are red candles and it's
like
what are you telling me you just told me
that you know when the market is selling
off I should be looking for selling
imbalances yeah one that's the most
obvious sign that's where you start to
look for it
um the imbalance is coming in but again
you know I've talked about this what you
want to see is you want to see the
volume coming down on the offer side as
well and what I mean by volume coming
down is you want to see lower and lower
offers as well as as opposed to just
people hitting the bids I mean people
hitting the bids is going to push the
market down but what's going to keep it
down to stop it from going back up is
solid offers solid volumes on the offer
and often what you see on markets moving
down is
selling imbalances in those sorry
binding balances on those red bars
because what's happening is you know
Market just dropped here so like for
example right this is gold you know we
were just trading 16 uh 85 and a half
next thing you know we're trading 16 you
know 81.
but you know it would just dropped you
know four bucks you know in in a few
minutes it's going to attract buyers
right people always looking to buy
something on the cheap you know whether
it's you know a Futures Contract or or
whether it's you know your groceries
right especially you know we're always
trying to buy things at a lower price so
it's not uncommon to see you know the
selling that balances quickly on the way
down then when you sort of hit uh you
know an area after kind of a rotation
right four or five dollars in gold is
about a rotation
to see some buying come in and you're
seeing it but more importantly what
you're seeing is still you're seeing
Supply coming into the market that's
what's causing these imbalances because
now people that were shorting it up here
you know
maybe they're starting to cover some
down here right they're starting to
cover it or you know people that said
hey you know we just had this quick saw
off and you know this is a good buying
opportunity we just broke for four or
five dollars
um you know
I think we're going to rotate back up to
you know 85.86 so they're starting to
buy it in here right but that buying is
being absorbed
by passive sellers that's what's causing
these imbalances right because you still
see this Market dropping right you see
red bar with positive Delta
all right which is not what you expect
to see you know this is a bar Delta
Divergence right because normally you
would expect to see you know a red
candle with negative Delta right and a
green candle with positive Delta but in
this case what you're seeing is is kind
of the opposite you're seeing these red
candles with positive Delta because
people are absorbing Traders are
absorbing whatever buying is going on in
here because the sellers you know this
is like the clearest sign to you that
the big money the smart money so to
speak
is thinking this Market's going lower
right the whole thing about order flow
is following the big money following the
smart money I don't I mean is Big Money
smart you know generally we would think
so I mean there's a reason why they got
big money so they're supposed to be
smart right but it's not always the case
you know I've seen very big Traders make
make bad trades but anyway that's that's
another video but as we're going down
you're you're looking for signs of
potentially this keep going it's one
thing to just hit the bids that's what
you expect to see but when you see big
you know decent offers coming in to
absorb whatever selling or sorry
whatever buying is coming in after the
selling that's what you want to see now
treasury notes 10-year notes okay
similar thing right 145 rug got pulled
right everyone has
is just uh you know risk off get me out
of this Market in every Market it seemed
and you see right we're starting to come
down all right starting to tick lower
now treasuries trade a lot of contracts
and as we're going down selling a
balance selling a balance
buying a balance selling a balance
selling a balance selling a balance
buying a balance now granted you know
746 it's not 2 000 you know but it's
still that imbalance three against 746
this is a five minute
um 10-year note Futures chart Okay so
you know you're seeing you're trading
you know what 13 at 145 in the afternoon
it's trading 6894 contracts got negative
Delta of 1892. but you got this buying a
balance of 12.65. so what was happening
is Market's starting to break lower
right aggressive sellers are coming in
hitting these bids aggressively right
you don't see much volume here 190 395
1265 so as these people as these Traders
are clearing out these bids here 1183
1822 1300
you got a big offer coming in here
helping to keep pressure on this Market
to keep it going down
okay then the next bar more selling
coming in 1677 in Balance 1254 imbalance
23.84 imbalance okay look on the offer
side right you don't see much at the top
but then you see 2000 here to help keep
it down another 2 000 here to help keep
it down right Market breaks further look
at this bar here right you don't see
many much imbalances in here the volume
is kind of thinning out but down here 3
600 contracts on the offer traded
right that's your heaviest volume in the
bar
right as this Market is coming down
you're seeing strong offers as well on
the way down to keep it you know keep it
under pressure
right that that's what you expect to see
on a market that's got some very strong
selling taking place and you know it was
interesting because you know everyone's
obviously it was you know it was felt
like a long day today but
it's earlier that day I mean we had that
nice sell-off in the afternoon I mean it
was more dramatic it doesn't look as
dramatic here in the in the 10-year
notes because basically we're breaking
from you know 111 16 down 206 at 10
um 10 tick hold on authentic um you know
because trades in halves but you know 10
point move but earlier in the day we had
a nice rally actually
um you know also a nice you know over 10
tick move up we had this move right we
came down to uh you know 111 even then
we started rallying very strong
aggressive buying you could see in here
right the bar 20 000 contracts seven
thousand this is positive Delta right it
finished positive Delta 7700 so over 30
percent of the bar actually more you
know is uh aggressive buying over the
aggressive selling and you see buying
and balance buying and balance you got
what one two three four five six seven
buying imbalances but at the top you got
this nice big buying a balance that's
how you selling a balance in here
because now you have
um you know a big passive seller coming
in here to support this Market
right then the next bar again
trades 14 000 contracts nice you got
this big selling of balance this buyer
is absorbing whatever selling is taking
place
right again over here now you got this
red bar you know early in the bar there
was you know a big buyer here Market
dropped down but then the next part came
right back up you got the buying
imbalances at that same level where you
had those selling imbalances earlier
another
um
buying a balance here but look at this
bar okay this is interesting because it
traded 12 000
um contracts
where's the heaviest volume in this bar
it's right here on the bid side 25 26.
now this is not a imbalance
but it's your heaviest volume it's 25 25
versus 1671
so you know that there's obviously a big
support in this market just as and it's
coming in you know one tick above the
support that you had earlier which is
coming in uh
you know three ticks above the support
from earlier so I know I got you know at
06 there was support at oh seven and a
half support oh eight their support
all right so if this Market is going to
break down anytime soon
I know that at eight I got buyers at
seven and a half there were strong
buyers at six that were strong buyers
knowing that they're strong buyers in
there which do you think
is the direction of the trade probably
to the upside
okay you know I mean you don't need a
heat map to see this you can just see it
in a footprint it's very easy to see
right and you know this type of bar
you know in here is similar to when we
started coming back down here right you
see we're coming down
the heavy volumes on the offer side
right here at 08. you know on the way up
at 08 the heaviest side was on the
bedside you know in this bar I'm talking
on a bar by bar basis so recognizing
where these you know these big volumes
come in
again it's nice to see it when it's in
imbalance because it's very easy to see
because your eyes are sort of focused oh
you know there's a a red number or a
blue number in the footprint telling you
you know you have an imbalance but
sometimes it's not an imbalance
sometimes it's just
you know I'll say normal order flow
because it's bigger than your normal
order flow but just pay attention to
that right just look for
you know when you're looking at a
footprint just you know glance quickly
where's the biggest volume coming in is
it coming in on the bid side or the
offer side okay now which way is the
market moving so it's basically what
you're asking yourself is is support
coming in
or resistance coming in now by
resistance I don't mean you know just
you come up to a level hit it and come
off and that's your resistance what I'm
talking about is you know the the
resistance of
a strong seller offering resistance to
any move higher okay which is sort of
different than your run-of-the-mill
resistance thinking oh you know what we
come up here we hit this High you see
all this volume going through that's my
resistance as you start coming off this
is like in real time you're seeing the
support forming or this resistant
selling
um coming in here on the way down
okay so again you know it starts off
with imbalance but it doesn't always
have to be based around imbalance what
you should be watching for is the
volumes I mean imbalance makes it easy
to see but sometimes these things are
just a little bit hidden
that
you just got to look at it for you know
an extra two seconds and put the pieces
together to figure it out anyway guys
I'll end that video here you know I
really wanted to talk more about it
imbalances and it sort of deviated into
into a bit of volume
um but you know it's a natural thing
right in in the markets that's how it is
I mean everything is not cut and dry
it's not like
um you know you're you're in
you know art school or something and you
know all your crayon you know crayons
all your markers all your
um paint brushes are all neat and nice
and new but then when you're in the
studio painting you know your brushes
are all
um you know they got paint in them some
are stiff some are hard you know you got
to make new with you know what the
market provides you in that sense in
terms of
um
you know Market generated information so
anyway guys I hope you appreciate this
video
uh be sure to like and like the video
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already done so you know I said in the
beginning of the video I talked about
our new version of order flows Trader
um so you're probably gonna start to see
me working more things into my videos
based off of you know what you can see
on the order flows Trader again you know
this chart right here is a real basic
just you know I stripped it down because
I wanted to keep it simple
um but you know having software that can
do a lot of things for you in terms of
you know like for example you know our
just give you a sneak peek
um
our overflows Trader you know we've got
all these things buying Tails buying
selling Tails Delta Divergence
exhaustion prints
imbalance reversals you know inverse
volume and balance
um you know Market sweep detectors
Market weakness detector Order full
sequencing or obviously our ratios PLC
slingshot prominent points of control
and you know so much more and we've got
a bunches at least 19 and and there's
other things in here about reading the
Delta as well but um you know just leave
you with uh this real I mean one of the
things that I like to use in a market
like treasury notes is the um
stacked imbalances
whoops you know it's something that
actually not stack the bounces uh
probably controls I'm like going with my
glasses on but it's something that you
know when you add it to your chart
it
really
can help you see things that you know
you you've probably never noticed before
in the order flow and that was the whole
point of
um you know creating originally the
order flows Trader softwares you know I
wanted something that's going to help me
in my own trading and Analysis of order
flow and over time you know we've added
more and more things
um you know ways of reading the order
flow now this is
um Prominent Point of controls that we
draw out until tested now you can see
there's prominent pointed controls you
know colored magenta or
uh cyan but you know one of the the
other things that we added in this
version is to draw these out until
tested because these are Market
generated support and resistance levels
and you can see how this Market you know
we hit the support area came up to a
previous resistance area right up here
got one tick through it sold off as
we're coming down we kick off another
resistance area we sold down within a
tick of that prominent opponent control
rallied up to within a tick of this
Prominent Point of control sold off back
down you know we hit that area again
um it's kind of holding finally we broke
we had a bearish one here but the market
rallied up right through that but you
know it's just fascinating you know
here's another Prominent Point of
control from like the day before okay we
rallied literally right up to it just
got past it by two ticks yeah
and then we sold off again okay so again
you know I I'm excited because I got a
lot of things I could talk about now you
know on these videos because you know
honestly it does get uh you know just
looking at a normal footprint chart
trying to explain things to you guys
it's I can do it but there's so many
tools out there I don't understand why
people don't Avail of the tools
available
um you know
in trading
you know it's one of those things I saw
um
a meme sort of about this you know it's
just like you know if you have tools
available use them all right don't just
sit here and you know this is the
problem I think why a lot of Traders
give up on order flow is because
they start looking at a footprint like
this and again if they have sort of no
market experience they're coming in and
they don't understand a two-way auction
trying to figure out is going to take
time that's why you know we created the
order flows Trader software to make what
you're looking at a lot easier to see
because at the end of the day you know
when you're trading In the Heat of
battle you gotta be able to make
decisions quickly and that's what the
order flow is Trader software
is designed to do to help you make those
decisions you know quickly and
efficiently all right guys anyway I'll
end it there for now
um
so again you know be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel
thanks everyone bye bye